league of legal is sponsored by
curiosity stream and nebula get a
whopping 41
off for a limited time clark is supposed
to be the good guy in this movie right i
have a pet theory that clerk griswold
changes his name to pierce hawthorne and
goes into hiding after the events of
this movie i'll be a living god
hey legal eagles and welcome back to
laws broken where an attorney destroys
your favorite childhood movies by
showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal it's that
time of year again the time when
everyone on twitter says their favorite
christmas movie
is die hard well let me settle this once
and for all
die hard is not
a christmas movie die hard is
a christmas song but regardless of that
controversy let's all acknowledge that
chevy chase is the true hero of
christmas everyone watches national
lampoon's christmas vacation
at least twice during the holiday season
because nothing says christmas like
clark griswold this is
clark griswold and his family welcome to
our home
and we have so much empathy with clark
having to deal with his eccentric
relatives that
we completely overlook the fact that
clark has absolutely no regard for the
law whatsoever
once clark starts degrading the
neighborhood with broken windows and
trees and overloaded power strips other
more serious crimes start to pile up
in fact clark griswold may even be a
crime boss in the making and you thought
your family holidays were bad so let's
examine the laws broken in national
lampoon's
christmas vacation
[Music]
i hope he falls and breaks his neck i'm
sure he'll fall but i don't think we're
lucky enough to have him break his neck
all right here we have our first entry
into the war between the griswolds and
their yuppie neighbors todd and margot
chester and you may have lived next to a
todd the uppity neighbor who thinks that
he's better than you and he's above
silly christmas lights he's probably the
president of your hoa ready to enforce
all the neighborhood rules with an iron
apple
pencil or maybe you've experienced
living next to a clerk the dope who
doesn't care if his lawn or decorations
or family invades your space
really both of these guys are very
likely to have been the subject of an r
aita subreddit and if you know what that
acronym means
you aita now clark threatens to stick a
chainsaw up margo's
whatever where do you think you're gonna
put a tree that big bend over and i'll
show you you've got a lot of nerve
talking to me like that griswald i
wasn't talking to you
what a great family man and a lot of the
movie's slapstick elements involve
self-inflicted injuries to clark
but he gets plenty of hits in on other
people and property as well
clark's adventures in christmas
decorations leads directly to a piece of
gutter going through the neighbor's
window
you may think that was just a harmless
accident but clark has no remorse for
what he did so let's talk about criminal
damage to property clark's mishap
with the gutter is the first blow
against law and order now this is
possibly criminal damage to property
under illinois law and
under illinois law a person is guilty of
criminal damage if they perform any of
the following acts without the consent
of the property owner one
damages any property of another two
recklessly by means of fire or explosive
damages someone's property three
knowingly starts a fire on someone's
land four knowingly injures someone
else's pet
and five intentionally places a stink
bomb or any other offensive smelling
compound
on the land or in the building of
another with the intent to interfere
with its use
and by the end of this movie clark will
have committed basically all five of
these types of criminal damage clark
pretty clearly damaged his neighbor's
house the penalties for criminal damage
are based on the dollar amount of the
damage caused or
the type of property that was damaged
here this is a broken window but
he's going to have to pay for it a
violation of this first subsection is a
class a misdemeanor as long as the
damage does not exceed 500
i don't think the damage here exceeds
500 on the window however
this is not the last offense so let's
talk about the electrical code
violations clark doesn't stop with
accidentally vandalizing todd and
margo's house
next he engineers a power surge that
takes out the city's entire power grid
the city has to switch to nuclear
auxiliary power this may look like a
simple mistake but clark could be fined
by the city for his numerous probable
code violations
for example it's illegal to crowd a
service panel national electrical codes
recommend that a service panel have a
working clearance that is 30 inches wide
three feet deep and six feet eight
inches high and you tell me does it look
like they met that requirement here
national electrical codes also penalize
a homeowner for installing too few
receptacles the purpose of this of
course is to reduce the use of extension
cords and when homeowners screw this up
extension cords are far more likely to
start fires and create a tripping hazard
as we see
plenty in this film just check out all
of those cords the griswold home is
basically a walking fire hazard and
speaking of hazards and criminals
once cousin eddie comes to town the pace
of serious crimes escalates and would
you believe that randy quaid is actually
crazier than his on-screen counterpart
cousin eddie 2020 has been rough on us
all and here is one of the most infamous
scenes in this entire movie
what are you looking at an [ __ ] in
his bathrobe emptying a chemical toilet
into my sewer
[ __ ] was full yes he is emptying a
chemical toilet
into a storm sewer really all that's
missing from the top of this rv
is a trump 2020 flag but could cousin
eddie perhaps be misinformed sewage from
a chemical toilet has to go
somewhere so could it actually be legal
to dump sewage into the storm sewer well
obviously not cousin eddie violated
section 21 of the illinois environmental
protection act
which prohibits the open dumping of
waste violations under the illinois epa
are either a class a misdemeanor or a
class 4 felony in addition
section 47-5 of the illinois criminal
code provides that
dumping garbage rubbish refuse or trash
on someone else's property
without their consent is a misdemeanor
local chicago laws also make it illegal
to discharge quote any noxious or
malodorous gas or substance capable of
creating a public nuisance the city of
north chicago prohibits anyone from
dumping anything
into storm sewers and winnebago county
illinois seems to have written their law
with cousin eddie specifically in mind
quote no person shall discharge or cause
to be discharged untreated sewage
or the contents of any privy vault or
chemical toilet directly or indirectly
to storm sewers chicago takes this
pretty seriously just ask stefan wohl
the bus driver for the dave matthews
band he pleaded guilty to
emptying the bus's septic tank over the
chicago river in 2004
quote drenching passengers on an
architectural boat tour with 800 pounds
of human waste yes you heard that right
800 pounds
well got 18 months of probation 150
hours of community service and a 10
000 fight after pleading guilty to
misdemeanor charges of reckless conduct
and water pollution he also never drove
for the band again now these are of
course related to the actions of cousin
eddie who is distinct from clark
griswold
but it's possible that vicarious
liability could attach to clark in these
circumstances but remember our criminal
damage to property offense
clark could be charged with the fifth
kind of offense the intentionally
placing a stink bomb or
any other offensive smelling compound on
the land or in the building of another
with the intent to interfere with its
use the police might be able to say that
clark knew darn well what eddie was
doing to that sewer and that the
resulting stink interfered with the
entire neighborhood luckily for eddie
there's no law against public
drunkenness in illinois
so he only needs to fess up to dumping
the toilet so now we're getting down to
clark's baser criminal instincts where
he admits writing a check without
sufficient funds to cover it
to make sure the pool goes in as soon as
the ground thaws i had to lay out the
money in advance and until this little
miracle arrived i didn't have enough in
my account to cover the check i wrote
clark's excuse for this is that he
really really wanted to put a deposit
down on a swimming pool and he
assumed his bonus would cover it well
sorry but that won't cut it as a defense
to check kiting
under illinois criminal law writing a
check when you know you don't have the
funds to cover it is considered
financial institution fraud this is
considered theft from a financial
institution and when the total amount of
that financial fraud is between
three hundred and one and ten thousand
dollars that's a class three felony
which carries a possible sentence of up
to five years in jail
or a fine of up to twenty five thousand
dollars but then clark goes on and
further crime spree which again inflicts
property damage on the chester house
after the tree smashes into the window
this is clark's fault and this time the
damage is well above the 500
threshold for a misdemeanor the penalty
for this criminal charge could be a
class 4 felony in illinois when the
damage the property exceeds 500
but doesn't exceed 10 thousand dollars
which is punishable by three years in
prison and a fine of up to 25 000
but the neighbor margot is not going to
take this lying down and margot's fed up
with a vandalism to her house so she
decides to take the law into her own
hands
i can't just attack someone all right
then if you're not man enough to put an
end to this
that i am she tells todd she's going to
kill clark and
marches over to his house snots the dog
chases after a squirrel running out of
the house
and mauls her now illinois has a strict
liability dog bite law
under the statute quote if a dog or
other animal without provocation attacks
attempts to attack or injures any person
who is peaceably conducting himself or
herself
in any place where he or she may
lawfully be the owner of such
dog or other animal is liable in civil
damages the law makes the owner of the
dog or the person controlling it liable
to the injured person
in tort now margot could claim that the
dog was told to attack her but that's
not necessary for a strict liability
offense
however on the other side provocation is
a defense so clark might be able to
claim that it was a hideous accident
caused by a flying squirrel
[Music]
and margot was in an aggressive posture
now margot is so pissed off about being
attacked that she quickly recovers
just in time to punch her husband in the
face in anger
this is basically turning into a law
school towards hypothetical
on steroids but under illinois law a
person commits battery if he or she
knowingly without legal justification by
any means one
causes bodily harm to an individual this
is a class a misdemeanor and she
probably doesn't have any defense here
but
luckily clark is probably out of the
woods on this particular one but
that takes us to the darker side of
clark and potential
kidnapping when clark tells the family
that his boss cheated him out of a bonus
he suggests kidnapping the boss and
having him brought to the house for a
beating i want him brought from his
happy
holiday slumber over there on melody
lane with all the other rich people and
i wanna brought
right here with a big ribbon on his head
ever the compliant co-conspirator eddie
kidnaps the boss ties him up holds him
against his will and brings him to clark
ho ho ho merry christmas clark
you better ready to do some kissing so
by now clark griswold is basically the
tony soprano of winnebago county when
the police finally arrive clark admits
that he is the mastermind behind the
crime and he ordered eddie to kidnap the
boss in like any good capo eddie did
just as he was told
it was my fault i lost my temper when i
got my bonus and i
i guess i said a few things i shouldn't
have but this was no
simple kidnapping aggravated kidnapping
includes taking another person with the
intent to collect a ransom or inflicting
any bodily harm on that victim clark
wanted a bonus big enough to cover the 7
500
deposit on a swimming pool this could be
enough to conclude that the boss was
ransomed i have never been treated like
this in my life
i'm sorry this is our family's first
kidnapping and aggravated kidnapping is
a class
10 felony with prison terms increasing
with the nature of the crime first
offenses are punishable by a prison term
of
6 to 30 years with an additional 15 to
25 years depending on the severity of
the crime
second and subsequent offenses are
punishable by life imprisonment and a
fine of up to 25 000
and restitution to the victim clark is
supposed to be the good guy in this
movie right i
have a pet theory that clerk griswold
changes his name to pierce hawthorne and
goes into hiding after the events of
this movie
pierce you've had three flu shots that's
for the daycare center
i'll be a living god now the best part
of this search for the griswold family
christmas tree is clark leading an
expedition through knee-high snow
we may all dream of striding through the
woods and cutting down a perfect
christmas tree but
as avid readers of r slash tree law can
attest you have to consider the location
of the tree
is this private property we're clearly
far away from the tree lot at this point
and that's probably a crime this could
be trespass or conversion since the
griswolds are on someone else's land
they've also violated the illinois
wrongful tree cutting act under this law
any party to have intentionally cut or
knowingly caused to be cut any timber or
tree other than a tree or woody plant
referenced in the illinois exotic weed
act
which he or she did not have a legal
right to cut or cause to be cut
shall pay the owner of the timber or
tree three times
its stumpage value that's an enormous
tree that is probably worth tens of
thousands of dollars clark could be on
the hook for fifty thousand dollars
this tree is a symbol of the spirit of
the griswold family christmas
now before we tally up all of clark's
crimes and sentence him to a jail term
let's look at all the other dishonorable
mentions of minor crimes by others
christ the lord
we kick things off with a crime against
music courtesy of clark and ellen
nailed it there are enough moving
violations in the scene that we could
use it for a law school exam
hypothetical and here
this could easily be child endangerment
audrey's eyes are
literally frozen ellen is skeptical
about inviting the whole family to stay
with them for christmas
i think you're forgetting how difficult
it's gonna be having everybody in the
house at the same time
well ellen just wait until 2020 when
getting that many family members
together in the house violates several
states covet 19
orders and bethany puts her cat inside
of a box and wraps it up they also kill
the cat in the middle of this movie that
thing had nine lives she just spent them
all
and as you know when it comes to their
own misdeeds cats are above the law but
it is illegal to harm them illinois
makes animal cruelty a misdemeanor sorry
aunt bethany but you'll be spending new
year's behind bars a class c misdemeanor
carries a jail stint of up to 30 days in
jail
you know you shouldn't have done that oh
dear
did i break wind and to cap it all off
uncle lewis lights a match that sets
this sewer aflame are we going to charge
this old man with criminal mischief
yes yes we are but back to our hero
of this movie it's now time to sentence
clark griswold
[Music]
clark griswold gets one year in jail and
a 25 000 fine for the
felony of dumping 3 years and 25 000 for
the felony of theft of a financial
institution one year in jail and a 25
000
fine for the felony criminal damage to
property and 10 years in jail for the
felony of
aggravated kidnapping for a total of 15
years in prison
and fines totaling 75 000 so confirmed
clerk griswold is just the worst as a
matter of law
hallelujah holy sh
where's the tylenol and if you're the
kind of person that loves destroying
christmas movies
i continue the legal destruction of this
movie over at nebula i posted a whole
extended version of this video on nebula
in fact almost all of my videos have an
ad-free extended version
exclusively on nebula believe it or not
annoying christmas light displays have
made it all the way to the supreme court
because sometimes even legal issues are
too hot for youtube because youtube's
algorithm can be quite capricious which
is why my creator friends and i teamed
up to build our
own platform where creators don't need
to worry about demonetization or the
dreaded algorithm it's called nebula and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad-free and also
experiment with original content in new
series that wouldn't work on youtube not
only are my nebula versions ad-free and
extended but they're also released early
before the youtube version
and nebula features lots of youtube's
top educational-ish creators like
philosophytube
fish and adam nealy and we also get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on youtube and put out amazing original
content like
half as interesting as courtroom drama
which i guess star alex nicholls show
alex goes bananas where i
guest star and lindsey ellis's
documentary about whether blazing
saddles could be made today
which i took no part in whatsoever so
what does all of this have to do with
curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet they love
educational content and educational
creators and we worked out a deal where
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
the link in the description
you'll also get a nebula subscription
for free and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member and until the
end of the year curiosity stream is
offering
41 off of all of their annual plans
that's less than 12
a year for both curiosity stream and
nebula together
after that you'll get 26 off which is
still a smoking hot deal
for both curiosity stream and nebula so
if you click the link in the description
you'll get both curiosity stream and
nebula for 41
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly for less than 12
a year for both curiosity stream and
nebula so just click on the link in the
description or go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis do you think
clark should go to jail
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other
laws broken videos including how many
laws kevin mcallister broke in home
alone it's one of my favorite videos
ever so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court